pump the brakes there gang get over to
that are you garbage.com and pick up
some ayg gear we're talking T Zippo
style lighters you got the kippies
heaters and cooling you got the garbage
shirts you got the Bernie shirts do
yourself a favor pick something up for
the one you love also it's the one stop
shop for all ayg Live show tickets maybe
there's still some tickets left to the
second show but it's going to sell out
in Red Bank New Jersey get those tickets
now Friday August 11th don't snooze
Cause You're Gonna Lose yeah welcome to
another exciting edition of
[Music]
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that if
the girl to be classy yeah or to just a
big old piece of trash I'm your host
Dave Foley coming at you on a beautiful
day we're out back here with Toadies in
the new edition she's out in the Poconos
okay picking up a couple life guarding
shifts okay can't swim but she can make
a 9-1-1 call if she needs stuff fair
enough my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me unamused this week he
is the CEO of are you garbage he's my
best pal in the whole wide world even
though we don't laugh at my jokes give
it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan what up
gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate view subscribe
on iTunes full video of album YouTube as
you know those numbers are and then the
greatest website of all time in the
books call up Guinness it's in the books
www.patreon.com are you garbage gang
sign up over there it's a goddamn party
we're having fun over there gang and
having a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the Magic Man
makes us all look good works the ones
the twos the threes and the fours he
crosses the t's and he dots the eyes
give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby
McMullen everybody what up boys what's
up pal dude I'm stoked we got one of the
Young Guns that's a cool kid in here
looks like he knows his way around an
Xbox controller in a 3D Dorito yeah I'm
trying to fudge my Tick Tock numbers
let them know that I'm in the know I
know what's going on gang the long hair
ain't lying we couldn't be more excited
to have our incredibly and I mean
incredibly special guest here with us
today for the first time he is one of
the Rising Stars over there in the bar
stool universe universe
God damn it I look cool
now he's not going to kiss you
now I'm not getting invited to the
Hamptons this weekend you can hear him
every week on son of a boy dad and of
course the yak give it up for a little
sass everybody there he is thank you
internet
this is awesome never combed his hair
I'll tell you that look at him oh man my
hair is I've been trying to figure it
out for 22 years I still haven't what
are you putting in that everything I
thought it was going to be nothing in
whatever dude my hair is like stick
straight so if I don't put anything in
it it's just like a bowl cut yeah that's
a tough look it's it's tough It's hard
it's like a little Danish boy I know it
probably looks bad right now I wish I
could no it looks it's good it looks
perfectly disheveled yeah you have the I
don't care yeah I care type yeah but I
do I do care
if I didn't care I would not put
anything in
three hours give us the back story where
did you grow up I have my ideas I'm from
Massachusetts from the suburbs of
Massachusetts okay yeah mom dad brothers
sisters yeah I got a mother a father
both of them and I have uh three sisters
three are you the youngest no I am the
second oldest I have two younger sisters
and one older sister okay how far apart
are they
uh my older sister's like a year older
than me all right and my younger sister
is four years younger than me and then
my other younger one is maybe six years
younger than me so they're in high
school one of them just graduated high
school like two weeks ago another one is
going into High School you are by far
the youngest person we've had on the
show Yeah by like a decade yeah probably
wow
wow brother off anything for the
graduation I don't have a brother sister
sorry sorry I did have a brother I gave
her cash oh
500.
[Applause]
get the [__] out of here all right
classic saving all that money on hair
products
are you [__] me I mean I don't know
it's graduation oh that's good we were
just talking you were gonna do 100 or
50. I was gonna do four for who for my
cousin who's graduating high school oh I
wouldn't get my cousin anything
yeah it's my younger sister he owes me
20 dogs yeah what'd your parents say
about that uh my Dad tried to not let
her have it yeah he was like she can
have a hundred of it it was actually
like a whole I was on my way to the
train station going back to New York and
he was like she can have a hundred and
then I had to call him like what it's my
money I was what the [__] are you
talking about yeah yeah yeah what did uh
what did your parents do I'm sorry no
what do you mean what do they do for
work my dad works in insurance and my
mom I thought you meant for graduation
he gave her 50 bucks yeah you're making
me look like a jerk off out here you
want all your New York money get out of
here the quarter's been slow what do you
want from me
holy [__] your dad works in Insurance
yeah sales uh like I.T okay yeah all
right and your mom my mom has not had a
job since for a while okay yeah so your
dad's doing all right my dad's doing
good yeah how old are your parents who
don't mind me asking gotta be your age I
was thinking that yeah for sure you're
they're 50s yeah no [__] yeah my my
dad's I dude I have no idea
these young kids
they're both over 50. I know they're
both over 50. all right like 52 53.
that's crazy yeah my dad's younger than
my mom at like two years and how old are
you exactly 22. so I could be your dad
how old are you 47. ah yeah really are
you actually Four yeah damn you look
younger clean that room I'll tell you
that I know I'm 28. are you ready
dude I don't know we had a [__] War
mode on our podcast oh yeah dude Billy's
30. yeah Billy looks like he's [__]
60 right now dude yeah I was I was like
dude you're eight years older than me
T-Bone
podcast and you really ages yeah
um uh they you still live in the same
house that you grew up in I assume right
yeah yeah
um what's that situation is it you don't
give it away but is it a street is it a
road is it an Avenue like you know
Mockingbird Lane Avenue Road uh well
actually no we moved once
okay
we moved in within the same town okay
okay yeah is that are you close to boss
is it Boston it's like uh 30 40 minutes
from Boston no one's actually from
Boston right right right right right
right people like to say they are sure I
tell people I'm from Boston okay from 45
minutes away from Boston yeah but that's
I mean that's one of those things it's
like if you said the name of your town
and you go where is that and you go 45
minutes outside yeah culturally you're
from Boston exactly yes you root for the
sports teams it's yeah yeah yeah of
course
huh all right okay well it's a
supermarket they shopped at growing up
and now oh that's a good one Market
Basket Hannaford's yeah
was the one that we grew up shopping at
and I think now it's Stop and Shop stop
and shops are good okay all right not
bad High School yeah when
[Laughter]
I did it yeah what was the name of the
mascot dragons the dragon the dragon
that's not bad that's kind of new agey
though maybe no yeah like Harry Potter
Vibes what were your mascots I was the
Hawks yeah I was the Hawks Trojans
Trojans popular ones yeah everyone's all
right yeah yeah it was easy you slapped
a guy on there yeah yeah Trojans are
easy some kid in the helmet running
around in football games saving the
artwork uh how are the grades in high
school really bad really really bad we
were actually just talking about three
years ago that's crazy
well I was in the middle of the pandemic
yeah I did uh terrible in high school
did you take the SATs I did and what'd
you get on them terrible it's out of 20s
was out of 2600. when I was 16. 1600
yeah what'd you get
oh I got an 870 so don't feel bad all
right I got I think I got it up to an 11
or maybe a 10. we had four digits we
operate but I took it multiple times did
they take it did you have to get tutored
for it yeah because I did the I did the
first time like little studying little
tutoring and I was like dude I [__]
aced that and then I got it back and I
got like a 7 10. yeah [__] which is like
I think you get 400 points yeah it's one
of those things yeah showing UPS half
the thing you know yeah that was really
bad oh okay did you go to college did
you go to school I went to school for
like six months where'd you go uh DePaul
in Chicago that's a good school yeah
it's okay isn't it the Paul's a good
school to get into
I think it's pretty easy to get and then
you dropped out dropped out yeah you're
a College Dropout yes look at you now
kids doing it yeah yeah well how are
your parents how does your parents react
when you wanted to drop out of so I
dropped out so I got sent home this was
right in the beginning of the pandemic
was when I was a freshman in college
[Music]
I had already crashed and burned that
was like I was too dependent I think I
was like a Phoenix Rising nice little
Wicked drug problem yeah holy [__] so I
dropped out right when I so the pandemic
happened like six months in and I got
sent home and then I was at home and I
was started doing bad I was doing good
in college up until then right and then
Barstool reached out to me and then I
got hired there and then I dropped out
right away and then my parents were like
I was like the original plan was like
I'm gonna give it a year if it doesn't
work out I'll go back to so you had to
do online classes at home for like three
months damn that's crazy yeah
that's are you back in your old room uh
yeah I was mostly just sitting in the
basement just [__] playing Minecraft
a lot of Minecraft I went through a big
Minecraft phase these days yeah my
nephew plays that he's like dude
Minecraft is fun as [__] if you if you
tried playing Minecraft you'd be like oh
this is awesome that's the one that's
all pixelated right it's fun I keep
thinking very relaxing I keep thinking
of mine sweeper
I was like damn this kid is really
loving Windows holy [__] okay Young Buck
huh what were the pets like growing up
uh we had dogs all my life uh ran
through a couple of them like you know
and then now I have two dogs okay yeah
family has two dogs family is two dogs I
have no dogs what kind of dogs are they
uh like mixes a bunch of [__] okay your
parents are adoption people yeah okay
what are the names Lilo and Stitch we
did not pick those names that's how they
they named really okay yeah stolen from
Disney I know I know
um where's your parents where'd your dad
go to college Babson Bab
babson's in Wellesley Massachusetts okay
and what's there what's their lineage
did your parents come from money they
start from the bottom no neither of them
come for money oh my dad came from money
and then they lost all of it all right I
know that story yeah and then and then
yeah then they were like poor as [__]
and he grinded his way out of it yeah I
imagine he does pretty good my dad does
good yeah what's he whipping around town
and what kind of car does he drive uh uh
BMW
yeah okay yeah all right you gotta pull
in that backyard no no pool no pool
garage
no no garage no garage how many single
family home or like a townhouse a condo
we just have a driveway driveway yeah
okay okay how many bedrooms is the house
right it's a five bedroom house it's for
uh we all have our own room okay yeah I
guess Dad dad and my mom share a room
really I know right what's that so we're
kind of slumming it it's closing deals
they sleep in bunk beds
they're not doing anything weird up
there
um if we went back to your house right
now what would your bedroom look like
would it look like oh this is a guest
room it would be like oh this is it's
still made up no it's it's like a guest
room okay there's nothing in it all
right if you have any posters on your
walls I did Growing Up but it's my
bedroom's completely empty and what's
down in the basement is it is it
finished
um no so what were you doing when I no
so you were just you were literally down
in the basement like next to the
dehumidifier playing Minecraft yeah
pretty much it's kind of a shitty
basement it's it's I wouldn't say it's
finished were you smoking doobies down
here no I was drinking a lot
like it was like no one would go out and
buy beer so I had to drink like 13 ipas
that had like flakes at the bottom were
you 21 at the time no okay I was 18.
Jesus or 19. I guess I was 19 at the
time
this kid plays it fast and loose what
was indoor tight I'm not sure what was
your job's growing up did you start did
you work when you were a kid yeah I uh I
had some I I was just bad I was bad at
everything you know are you guys good at
things when you were younger like you
guys play sports or anything yeah yeah
would you play I wasn't good at that
football wrestling on the cross oh wow
you were an athlete yeah a little bit
the Cool Sports yeah I played lacrosse
for like two years okay sucked all right
women's yeah I would have been probably
better at Women Australian League yeah I
uh yeah I had a I did a lot of
landscaping I started like a landscape I
started like a landscaping company when
I was like in eighth grade now we're
talking as it's called four guys one job
and we would walk to the houses
because we none of us could drive so we
just walk everything and what say hey
I'll use your yeah that was part of the
whole deal so you guys need to have it
you gotta have a lawnmower yeah yeah a
weed wacker yeah it was kind of like it
was more like odd jobs like one time we
moved one time me and one of my buddies
we had to move like a thousand just uh
cinder blocks from like one place to
another and I actually like exploded a
tendon in my arm doing it because it was
so much so many blocks moving around I
he's a goat together did you start an
LLC and all that stuff hell no no no
this was like two summers and then I got
uh then I started do I was a bus boy for
a while and what kind of restaurant uh
it was just like the one of the Town
restaurants it's a normal restaurant and
uh that was bad that was pretty bad I
was really bad at that I couldn't it was
a big restaurant like 200 tables maybe
and they'd be like bring this to 193 D
and I'd be like I don't know where the
[__] is 193 D and then I have to stare
at the [__] uh at the shark at the
chart yeah and then I and then I'd have
to go back out and like [__] I forget
where it is I have to go back in and
find the chart again I know that Panic
is shame every second seems like an hour
because you go back to the kitchen they
freak out what are you doing I told you
to bring that the 192 days dude I would
get yelled at a lot I brought out uh I I
started like getting confident in
bringing food out to tables and then one
day there was like a 12 person party big
ass table in like a private room and
they got someone got the fish tacos and
I saw the first tacos were under like
the hot lamp thing so I was like I'm
gonna bring the fish tacos out bring
them out go back to doing work and
someone else comes into the kitchen look
who the [__] brought out the fish
and I was like hi I just hate in the
dish pit and then I had to have a sit
down meeting mid-shift with the chef and
the manager in his in the manager's
office and they were like the fish tacos
were ready an hour before the rest of
the food so that guy's done with his
food and there's only five minutes for
everyone else's name yeah yeah that's
all so you know you [__] up when the
chef sits down in an office
yeah
yeah and then I had a job uh at like a
pizza sub place what was the name of the
pizza place in your town I was going to
ask uh that one wasn't in my town that
was in the town next to me it was uh
that one was called Cravings okay then
there was like a Benchwarmers
is that where would you guys get your
pizza growing up there you would
Benchwarmers get it from Bench Warmers
yeah Cravings sucked okay I mean I was
doing the pizzas oh holy [__] yeah I was
like the head of the pizza operation
yeah I got fired back I'm the CEO of
pepperoni right now you know you're
talking to him
this dude really spins it yeah I had a
landscaping company and you're about
lawn with other people's love but it was
mine we would post on like the Facebook
uh groups and we'd be like odd jobs I'm
the director
welcome to Four Guys and your equipment
the head of that operation though
because I would stop saying that no but
I was I was I was once
there's no operation I've heard of this
there was the four guys one job I would
wake up and I'd be tired and I would
just start sending other dudes out to do
the job I had like I had like a 20 dudes
working for me really from my bed
anybody older than you uh no like you
weren't sending out grown men or
anything hell no no no so at one point
it became 20 dudes and uh
my top guys you just like my time hey
Ricky you know you're you're one of my
top guys right as a director of this
operation come into my office for a
minute don't mind the Minecraft
um what were the family vacations like
we didn't really go on vacation a lot at
all we went to Florida once or once or
twice Disney uh we went to Disney when I
was really young I don't even remember
that okay yeah and then uh
we'd go like to get this down to Cape
Cod a lot my grandparents living okay
okay down there I'll tell you your
grandparents place going down the shore
first yeah huh and sports you just play
the cross for a little bit I played I
played everything growing up I played
baseball soccer hockey I played hockey
for a really long time that was kind of
like my sport for a while was really bad
at it and then uh I was kind of my sport
I was really bad I was not athletic and
then I played golf for in high school
which was actually awesome nice nice
course in your hometown so we would play
on the nice course yeah it was a private
course but it you would pay you you had
to make the team but then you'd pay it
was like 250 for a season and then you'd
play on the nice course every single day
for the all of the fall right yeah were
your parents members of the course no no
no not golf people no uh my dad is a
little bit now but it's still not
members do you still golf or no I
haven't played in a while okay are you
still on your parents Insurance yes are
you on their cell phone plan no
[Laughter]
yeah four guys one job actually covers
my insurance
it's a no-show job yeah you got great
benefits
I couldn't give it up
uh braces as a kid yeah nice how long
did you wear them geez too long too long
all of middle school and then up until
freshman year of high school were you
bad with them
uh yeah dude he's crushing that Vape I
don't know
it's kind of hot under these lights so
you're going through a divorce man
she took half the business I'm down to
two guys two guys no job you are the
embodiment of what every 60 year old guy
thinks gen Z yeah
time
he's wearing the Ghostbusters the
ironically too which is crazy okay let's
talk about rocket money rocket money
they got this goddamn inflation on who
knows what's going on jamming the kids
up there's still looking for ways to
save a couple of bucks Rock of money is
the way to go it tells you what
subscription you have and if you want to
cancel them right there you chop it on
the chopping block a lot of people think
they're doing about what 80 something
like that about 80 a month yeah it's
really about 200. yeah you ain't lying
rocking money quickly and easily find
your subscription and cancels the ones
you no longer want I didn't realize I
was signed up for butt plug of the week
I wasn't even getting the gosh dorm
packages canceled that toot sweet money
back in my pocket it also helps manage
your finances by category categorizing
your expenses so you can see where that
paycheck is going users the user saved
up to 720 per year that's a couple of C
notes in the pocket sure over three
million three million people have used
rocket money to get a handle on their
budget should stop throwing away your
money cancel unwanted subscriptions and
manage your expenses the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com garbage that's
rocketmoney.com garbage rocketmoney.com
butcher box baby you mean the box of
butchers let's talk about man just go
into your freezer and just seeing a
whole Treasure Trove a free-range
chicken of grass-fed grass finish beef
you've got talking Burgers the size of
your boobs big man good stuff I got two
racks of ribs in there that I'm waiting
for a special occasion to break these
babies out we love butcher box man you
don't know what you're getting when
you're at the grocery store you know
they change labels sometimes over there
you think you're getting something fresh
and it's from the Reagan Administration
yeah you're feeding your kids green hot
dogs you don't know what's going on yeah
you can get your nutrition on point with
the meats you can trust butcher box
sells humanely raise Cuts with no
antibiotics or no hormones you can even
customize your butcher box get exactly
the right kinds of meets for all your
favorite meals I let them do it because
they know what they're doing and they
send the kids or some fresh cuts yeah
surprise me uh butcher box has a special
deal just for the bozos sign up today
shout out to it let's go put your buy at
butcherbox.com
ayg use code ayg to receive free flanks
taking every box for three months
they're giving a flanks out plus 20
bucks off your first order no that's
right folks free flanks takes in
everybody wow with those flanks for
three months plus 20 bucks off your
first order when you sign up at
butcherbox.com you're giving a gosh
don't Farm away just butcher boxes use
code ayg one more time butcherbox.com
ayg promo code ayg do it
oh man crazy that is all right
um lunches growing up yeah what would
you would you bring to school bring
every day you would bring every day
who's making that lunch my mother your
mom would make it yeah you said that a
little disdain bad lunches bad lunches
why she you know what she would do that
would really like day ruin her you'd get
to like I mean lunch is like the bet
it's like the only positive part of the
entire course in high school and then
you'd get to lunch and I would open up
my sandwich and she would take the end
pieces and she would flip them inside
out so you wouldn't know they were end
pieces until you took a bite into the
sandwich and then you have two end
pieces and you're like you gotta be
[__] kidding man that's a day rule
it's a day Ruiner what kind of Sammy's
we talking it was always turkey or PB J
okay nothing ever in between that what
kind of drinks you throwing in there
soda none water drink yeah a bottle of
water I would just have water at school
Jesus yeah what about goldfish anything
like that crackers sometimes like uh
sometimes like a bag of chips it was
really it was light light launches what
was the pantry like at home was that
full or or no will be one of those
houses where it was like croutons and
it's no we got nothing I still go home
and I'm like there's no food and my
mom's like there's plenty of food I'm
like well I don't want to [__] make
like a whole meal right now I just want
something to eat right now no snacks no
snacks no good snacks cheese rough
snacks rough snacks yeah chips usually
chips we always had chips but that was
pretty much and only dogs no uh no birds
and no snakes no nothing like no birds
or snakes no okay hmm all right man huh
wild no vacations we would like we yeah
pretty much just go to the cape a lot
that's what people do up there though
yeah yeah how do you have your how old
were you when you got your passport
oh
17 and where'd you go I went to Europe
okay with the family I went on a school
trip okay yeah the weather is actually
really fun that was uh we went to
France and Italy
we took a train is this public school or
private school public school public
school yeah okay optional trip of course
you got to pay for it yeah yeah that's
run for that or is that four guys money
that's four guys yeah we had to take a
loan out I know definitely take you're
allowed to take one team trip as an LLC
it's a write-off talk to my account try
to expand operations into Europe
couldn't figure out the plugs so we came
back
wow what's the name of the mall in your
hometown
oh uh it's changed a lot it was it was
the Kingston mall originally I was okay
change to the independent small but I
don't even know if it really like is his
thing anymore well you would have never
had you and your generation you'd never
go there and hang out and stuff oh yeah
we would oh you would oh yeah it was
like the best place to yeah were you
skateboarding or anything like that or
rollerblading no we'd go like the movies
okay go to Spencer's and go look at the
dildos yeah all right there you go yeah
one time me and my buddy wanted to get
we were we were we decided that we
wanted to buy pocket [__] and we took
a bus to the mall to go buy pocket
[__] then we got there and all they
had was like a purple like alien vagina
pocket [__] and I was like yeah I think
I'm gonna pass on that what the [__] hey
wait you're gonna buy them as a joke or
like functionality of like a functioning
I want to [__] a pocket [__] today
Jesus today I didn't know they sold them
in the mall they don't they only saw the
alien ones
crazy mission to bring your bro on dude
oh yeah well it was both of us we
decided we were like yeah this is gonna
be a good idea
thank you okay yeah all right uh you
guys never did anything like that no I
mean I didn't go to the mall to buy sex
toys
I did see a movie every now again when I
was a Youngster
um all right so your mom was bad at
lunches how is she in the kitchen
otherwise
does she have a specialty dish what kind
of would you guys eat dinner as a family
every night like when you were in high
school we would eat dinner as a family
uh when I was in like middle school and
then high school we kind of stopped
doing that kind of just sit on the couch
and eat the whole family would sit on
the couch and you kind of just eat when
you ate gosh and then uh was she cooking
yeah what would you throw at you you're
chicken every single night always
chicken my kind of household yeah
meatballs sometimes okay basic meals
with the spaghetti meatballs yeah make a
meatloaf throw a meatloaf yeah there'll
be some meatloaf here and there all
right chilling out every now and then
what about breakfast what would you
normally having for breakfast bagel have
a bagel bagel cream cheese are they like
bought at a bakery or like like store
like like store ball in a bag store
buying a bag in the freezer uh sometimes
okay yeah all right what were you
driving to school in in high school uh
GMC Acadia I don't even know what that
is my mom's car it's like an issue it's
like a you know one of those Traverse
type so you would take her car and my
mom had one really yeah and she wouldn't
have a car all day oh no it was her old
car yeah she passed it down nice okay
and then it got passed down again to my
sister and then they got rid of it okay
do you have a car now in the city or no
no no no no
huh
okay very unique yeah wild is it a
little bit yeah
you were a business owner at eight
but my only one of my proudest
accomplishments he only had ends of
bread for some reason well I was I was
obviously not every day but sure when it
happened it was like once every month
and it would just destroy you yeah it
sucked really sucked okay uh are you
grocery shopping now at the house do you
ever go to the grocery store like in New
York yeah uh I did so when I first moved
here uh yeah like heavily and do you
have roommates now uh I just moved in by
myself just got a place by yourself like
two months ago one bedroom yes one
neighborhood uh West Village look at you
very nice kids doing all right yeah
that's Lil sass.com
it's actually a little Sasquatch
website.com
a director of
I mean you think you can you think you
know a guy yeah I don't know how that
came about I forget something was I
think little Sasquatch comedy and little
sassy so it's a little Sasquatch
website.com yeah
I don't know if there's another website
in the history of websites that has
websites I I don't hate it Squarespace
websites doesn't even have websites
right now all right so you move into the
you get your own place yeah
um do you get new furniture and all that
stuff I got a couch you got a couch
sectional no just a regular straight on
straight on camera new brand new or you
buy used uh brand new okay what's the
bed situation queen king single uh full
Queen full yeah I don't know is it a
full or a queen I think it's a full all
right yeah okay and that's on the ground
what else is in your bedroom
dirty couple of milk crates you want
actually I think I actually have a
picture of what it looks like right yes
no please that's exactly what we want
it's like a Sex Dungeon it's baffling
purple dildos everywhere it's actually
uh it's kind of like
it's kind of like unsettling this is
from my point of view of the uh of of oh
my god
dude can you see that from there oh yeah
we'll drop it in that's just literally
an insane asylum
there's a window and it's small and
there's no sunlight that gets into it
because it looks out into like the
finale way yeah do you have an AC in
there no no AC on this one in yeah I'm
gonna get one yeah you'll be cooking in
there all summer yeah it's it's uh well
the things I didn't use the bedroom for
a while what's up on the couch I just
had my mattress in like the main room
and then uh and like the the big the
bigger room and then uh I just moved to
bed in I think last week okay so there's
nothing on the walls it's just a
mattress on the ground what's the rest
of the apartment now that the mattress
is in the proper domicile what's in the
new room a cow or in the big room as you
can uh couch desk TV okay what's a TV on
uh it's on top of like the fireplace
mantle oh it's mounted
oh there's a manta okay yeah okay
fireplace doesn't work I assume no no
okay how big is the TV
50 45 all right yeah yourself a decent
TV yeah got the Xbox hooked up oh yeah
okay yeah actually I play Playstation I
play Playstation but I played on a small
a smaller TV on my desk really yeah you
got to get close you gotta play on like
a monitor like that you gotta get close
that's how you're supposed to play you
can't play from far away or else it'll
be lag you got the headset and all that
stuff oh yeah big gamer play a lot of
video games what's in your refrigerator
right now gamer juice G fuel I uh
G Fuel and talkies no I play uh in my
refrigerator I I tried out hellofresh
for a while okay love Hello friends yeah
but uh
I have a mini fridge oh my God yeah so
the so the the meats were going bad so I
think there's no freezer yeah I might
have to steer away from the Hello
friends you have the life in 8th grader
Dream Zone yeah but I'm I'm I'm cooking
for myself which is good because I I
went through like a two-year phase of
just ordering everything you gotta is
there a stove in there yeah okay
stovetop stove top yeah Alvin no no oven
no oven just a stovetop stovetop wait
how's that possible what's underneath
the stove top mini fridge
this is at Rikers you said right
wait how did you have that it's just uh
it's an electric stove top
so it's like just the there's two stove
top cookers it's a hot plate you have a
hobby yeah pretty much and then below it
is the mini fridge there's like a
there's like a platform yeah
I just keep forgetting you so I'm like
he's 22. he's got a place in the West
Village he's Richie Rich at this point
and no roommates yeah that's correct
it's crazy you didn't buy this place did
you yeah now rented yeah I lived in West
Village before too for a year and I I
had two roommates there but that
apartment was really small okay really
small like all I had was a bed okay and
that was I would play Playstation again
and I would have to sit it was at the
end it was at the foot of my bed on the
window but I would just sit crisscross
applesauce closer to the
uh because I said crisscross applesauce
yeah yeah Anthony that's just a force of
habit I say that all the time it feels
weird not throwing in the applesauce at
the end as you say crisscross yeah it's
a nice little dessert yeah applesauce
yeah of course yeah so that's how just
for generational purposes what was your
favorite cartoon growing up when you
were a kid oh uh well I I actually
really growing up I really liked uh Tom
and Jerry for a while of course I would
watch that a lot and then uh I got into
South Park SpongeBob was great okay
um so that was kind of your you were a
SpongeBob kid SpongeBob mostly yeah all
right is that what was popular at the
time yeah definitely okay yeah I mean
that was probably I mean that was huge
it's got to be one of the biggest
ever ever I just didn't know if he
caught it when it was at its actual
popularity or you know he's a little
he's an offbeat kid no it was definitely
at its popularity okay yeah all right
um how many suits do you own now none do
you know how to tie a tie yes okay yeah
how'd you learn that uh just I think I I
do it like the easy way I can't do like
the perfect trying I do like you go down
around up and down yeah so that's what I
know how to do yeah I think it's called
the Pratt knot now if you had to go to a
wedding next week yeah what are you
wearing I would have to rent enter by a
suit you go to h m grab something look
sharp yeah okay any of your friends
getting married or anything like that or
you're still too young for that uh yeah
no no one no maybe my cousin I think my
cousin's gonna get married soon so have
you gone to a wedding as an adult like
on your own never been to a wedding
you've never been to Hawaii now let's go
into businesses
there's a little kid you were never like
the uh I don't know something no never
no kidding yeah are we ever a pallbearer
no have you ever been to a funeral no
really yeah I've never been to a funeral
never been to a wedding have you ever
been in a limo no no if you're put in a
car yes okay man you never been to Old
never wedding or a funeral now you got
your whole life in front of you
that's [__] awesome
holy [__] yeah I think it is abnormal
though that I've never been to a wedding
or a funeral yeah a little bit because
you figures are both your grandparents
still alive all my grandparents are
still alive everybody's 66. no they're
old they're old they're in they're like
they're 80s and 90s okay
no [__] all right oh man
um this is such a different aspect of
the game we've never played it's crazy
um what do you like to drink not booze
wise but like you know Kevin likes Diet
Coke what do you drink diet coke you're
a Diet Coke DC man yeah DC uh Lacroix
okay any any sparkling water Seltzer but
then I got really into Diet Cokes the
the sparkling cells there's a gateway to
Diet Coke do you have that stuff in the
mini fridge now is there so you got Diet
Cokes and Lacroix in there Diet Cokes
Diet Dr Peppers
Lacroix that's the whole fridge
but you gotta prioritize the drinks are
the most important part you're throwing
at the pork loin yeah yeah Diet Cokes in
there yeah uh do you drink Prime energy
drink I do not know okay
that's that's way younger than me is it
that's it that's like children dude it's
[__] fantastic is it really it is
it's like one gram of sugar yeah that's
blowing up right now yeah it's huge yeah
Logan Paul yeah that was all right tall
drink of prime
um if we came to your house right now we
were over at the house and we said hey
can we get a glass of water what glass
of water what would you give us
glass of water diet coke well but it
would be it would be in a red Solo cup
it would be in a red Solo cup from the
faucet yes respect that though as a 22
year old you don't get the Brita it's
from the you can't you you're not you
know you're not gonna stay on top of
washing glasses I assume you don't have
a dishwasher no yeah so it's like the
Red Solo Cup is the best way to do it to
stay on top I have mugs for coffee but
that's it what can you make coffee in
the house yeah you got a French press I
got a Keurig you got a Keurig I got one
of those one cup Keurigs sure it's like
super convenient uh where are you
getting the carrot cups from are you
going live I steal them from Barstool
okay there we go I mean dude there's a
thousand of them I just I put them in my
backpack and I have them for a month
it gets all over the place dude
squirrely so you do so you will go to
the grocery store
yeah I haven't been in a while but I'll
be going to uh there's a grocery store
near my apartment I think it's called
Brooklyn Fair way too expensive Village
everything yeah jammed up I used to go
when I was really going to the grocery
store I'll go to Trader Joe's gentlemen
yeah all right who's what are you doing
the laundry uh just a wash and fold just
go to a washable drop it off pick it up
yeah if you go home
say you go home I don't know Fourth of
July weekend you go to your parents can
you bring laundry and your mom will
knock it out for you I do it myself but
I I when I go home I bring every pair of
underwear that I have so you can wash it
there yeah will you do in your laundry
when you were living there
yeah for the most part really yeah man I
am a loser
his mom still does it really really your
kid's over here doing his own goddamn
book like a business owner all right uh
do you currently have all matching socks
God now you're mad your socks don't
match right now oh right what I'm
wearing right now yeah they're matching
okay ankle socks no you go hi boys hi
boys really black or white white is that
what the kids are doing now White's back
yeah white attack
okay because back when I was banging you
got caught with white socks those things
came with a wedgie really oh you
couldn't do it yeah it's like black
socks like and I'm talking I'm thinking
like more like shorts like I'll wear
black socks if I'm wearing pants but if
I wear shorts I can't wear black socks
wear white socks yeah okay yeah it's
opposite to me really I can't I mean
it's just the time we grew up in white
socks were then it was when black socks
dropped it was like if you had white you
were yeah it was like your dad what's
the undies situation boxer briefs what
are you rocking boxers straight boxes
yeah you can read on this [__] guy I
can't wear a boxer briefs actually I
[__] hate wearing boxer briefs I I
was at work recently and I had boxer
briefs on and I left and I went to Old
Navy and bought boxers and changed in
the office and threw away the box of
briefs
I think they're so uncomfortable
are you wearing boxers your whole life
yeah it seems Miss generational doesn't
it I'm a boxers man you're 36. I'm 33.
whatever don't embarrass me in front of
the cool team
this guy's a cop dude
huh what was the nice what's the nicest
restaurant you've been to In the last
365 last year I went to lay Bernard n uh
for the yeah for for the show okay
outside of someone outside of a rich guy
paying for your meal none none I went to
Ford Charles prime rib okay but Francis
took me oh yeah
okay yeah I don't really go is he
yelling at you when Fork to use and
stuff like that 100 like he holds the
menu in front of you and like reads it
to you like telling you what you need to
do that's my wife that it's the most
degrading yeah in the world oh it sucks
can't let's talk about Adam and Eve
owner alert talk about getting weird in
the privacy of your own home with
somebody or if you're flying solo
there's no better way to spice things up
than a little Adam and Eve you know what
I mean buddy singles couples groups
whatever you're into anything Adam and
Eve if you want to go to the chase day
you're talking about climate change
they're talking about all this stuff
that's kind of get weird man stick
something up your butt get a sex swing
who cares yeah man have fun uh right now
you can get borrow time here right now
you can get 50 slam it in there stop it
right now Jesus Christ right now you can
get 50 off just about any item plus free
shipping and Rush processing engage your
heart and you don't want to lose it no
[__] dude so you got a buzz going
you can get it on as soon as possible if
you're still living in your mom's
basement like a lot of people I know
don't worry Adam and Eve has discreet
packaging uh she'll never have to know
you're stocking up on a harness set and
yikes well she might come down when she
comes down the vacuum she might catch it
turn the TV up real loud don't wait
better sex is just a click away that's
50 off one item free shipping with free
Rush processing just go to
adamandeve.com and select any one item
enter code garbage at the checkout this
is an exclusive offer just for ayg
listeners baby just for the Army garbage
be sure to use code garbage and get your
disc count 100 free shipping and Rush
processing that's adamandeve.com promo
code garbage adamandeve.com code garbage
donut back to that guy storm show Gang
back to the show uh will you and your
boys go out to eat together
Chipotle or something probably right
yeah like say you're going out like the
city on a Friday night well you guys all
go out to dinner and then go go to a
club or something like that do you do
that or you just mostly going to just do
the stash out of the stand yeah yeah
yeah he's in comedy world where it's
like you know
okay
if I if I hang on my buddies from a home
one of my friends is like a chef cook so
he he likes to go to like good food
places and how will you guys break that
checkup
we'll split it you'll split it will you
split it in the moment like here's four
credit cards or somebody will put down a
card and everybody will get a venmo
request usually that use a venmo request
I pay for a lot of stuff now sure
because none of them have jobs gotcha so
they don't yeah no are you still venmo
request them or don't worry about it I
got it I'll just I'll just take it
kid right kid old he's an old soul well
you send a venmo request to somebody if
they yeah no unless it was like a
thousand dollars more really I mean it
depends on what it's for like for for
drinks or for food if if it's like the
next morning I'm not gonna no
do you like uh any any of the Finer
Things in life like do you like a nice
hotel oh yeah you do yeah okay what I
did Francis made me do this too I I
bought a Delta one Protege oh yeah he he
hates the way I live so much probably
should not even being funny like you're
probably genuinely has she seen that
bedroom no no he would lose never let
him come in my heart he would he would
have an aneurysm he would lose his mind
there's no Boston Terrier what's going
on yeah where's your centerpiece where
do you keep your skis at
shout out to Francis yeah Francis is
awesome but uh
Francis made me or he convinced me to
fly uh Delta one with him great right
okay we were co-headlining Cobbs in San
Francisco nice long flight yeah long
flight did it awesome can you go back
now
ah yeah I I don't have it I can't I
can't justify spending that much money a
thousand dollars on a plane ticket sure
and you're comfy and Coach right yeah I
mean my legs slam up against the seat in
front of you sure but it's doable well
you put your seat back when you're in
coach when you're on a plane yeah I try
but sometimes they really just don't go
back that far it really doesn't do much
okay I recently got a neck pillow which
has kind of been Game Changer look at
you yeah you can catch up the 401K yeah
ah take your shoes off on a plane
yeah yeah will you bring food on the
plane every time not like what kind of
food are you talking like you tell me a
meal what do you take on don't go I
can't get on a plane without snacks okay
give me a rundown of the snacks did you
hold on and did you do that when you
were on Delta wanted to Francis say hey
you don't got to do that they're going
to give you snacks when you get on there
I didn't do that because we almost
because I we both almost missed the
flight it was at JFK are you TSA
pre-check no clear not clear clear okay
good yeah
um snacks
Pringles Diet Coke water
you gotta have Diet Coke and the water
yeah and then they serve different
purposes yeah exactly and then usually a
candy Jolly Ranchers okay you're a Jolly
Ranchers man like a bag of Jolly
Ranchers you'll just crush them just
crush the hard ones are like the tacky
ones really the Taffy ones are [__]
good though man you are old school Jolly
Ranchers well my ears my ears field trip
wait what do you mean your ears it helps
with my ears my ears pop a ton of planes
are you so when you have a Jolly Rancher
are you are you crushing it and chewing
it are you sucking on it
planes usually suck on them
every other scenario I'm chomping them
really yeah good man yeah yeah I love
eating hard candy like that yeah it's
all right
what would you say your favorite candy
bar is uh Heath bar score bar
are you a British spy did you say score
bar yeah what is that you might do is my
dad's favorite candy bar it's my mom's
favorite that's why yeah it's like a
heath bar it's toffee those things but
they're real classy they're good it's
Hershey's version of the heath bar it's
a very classy candy man there's a crown
in the oh yeah
s-k-o-r gentleman's car I didn't I would
I still don't have the confidence to buy
that
they're good huh are you peeing in the
shower yeah okay I actually don't even
know how people could not how do you not
pee
getting out of the shower to pee well
you brush your teeth in there no no
what's the what what's your bathroom
looking like now and who's cleaning the
apartment me you do yeah so you have as
much as I can you have a vacuum and all
that stuff no no no no no none of that I
meant like picking up trash don't have a
vacuum clean cleaner now I cleaned my
bathroom minimally last night I just wet
a paper towel and rinsed everything off
do you have any type of cleaning
products a little 409 or Fabuloso no
I've got I got like dial so I told you
about the paper towel in the water yeah
huh what kind of Bot what are you doing
body wash bar I got a bar and I got a
body wash and I got shampoo are you
going straight bar to skin or do you
have a Loof or anything like that smart
Skin Bar to skin yeah I'm living by
myself I don't either sure [__] I
don't need to lose jailhouse rules what
uh what kind of shampoo you're banging
with uh anything and how often are you
washing your hair every day you wash it
every day yeah I'd recommend not doing
it yeah I've heard yeah what do you like
a big because I know like if you break
through like the 30 days something it
starts cleaning itself or some [__] I
maybe once a month maybe is that like a
Rogan thing that's gotta be like a
roganism
I'd love that
I'll do it
um okay
all right how do you feel about
coleslaw's ass hated really I hate
coleslaw what was your mayonnaise
growing up in your in your parents house
was it Hellman's was it Miracle Whip and
Hellman's did you [__] with it oh love
mayonnaise you like me I love it you
don't like coleslaw no hate coleslaw
interesting you got hot sauce at the
house oh yeah what are we talking
everything really I love Hot Sauce you
go hot yeah really I I like to think I
did but then sometimes I I get tested
and I'm like oh maybe I'm not as much of
a hot sauce guy as I thought I was
what's like the hottest what's it called
the Scoville yeah I've had uh I I just
so I went to Iceland recently and I just
that's pretty cool yeah and I got all
these uh was that like a bakery and they
had a like a four pack of these like hot
sauces that they made in there they like
they're made with geothermal heat
something weird like that and uh
I just tried them out the other day
they're pretty good but that's like a
jalapeno habanero
then just like regularly yeah what were
you doing in Iceland I went with two of
my buddies just for vacation yeah okay
yeah so you're doing that kind of stuff
now you're you're getting out going
around that was the first time I've ever
we've ever really done that like Dawn
somewhere all together and how long ago
was this this was like
a month two months ago what's the
attraction of Iceland in April none it
was a big mistake we uh
it's dark out all day yeah yeah it was
uh I wanted to go to Switzerland sick
really bad I've done it you did I've
always wanted to go I was scrolling
Instagram and I saw it in Switzerland
thing and I was like dude I might go on
a vacation I was like I've never really
gone on a vacation like like set up my
own plans to go on a vacation so I was
like I'm gonna go to Switzerland one of
my buddies his mom's a flight attendant
so he flies for free okay he's like
let's go to Switzerland you really won't
be that expensive like you just have to
pay for like food and [__] and uh could
she get you to fly for free too no him
but I was like he can just go you can
afford the ticket your buddy dude it's
cheap as [__] to fly to Switz Iceland
okay but not Switzerland Iceland it's
like 300 because it's the closest yeah
yeah and uh everybody wants to go to
Switzerland yeah and then he called me
crazy expensive yeah yeah so is Iceland
is it I think it's actually the most
expensive country in Europe really yeah
Iceland's in Europe so how'd you land on
Iceland yeah isn't it I don't know I
never thought of that sounds like a
dumbass now no no that's me I never put
together what continent would be
included on
yeah I think theoretically it would be
in Europe yeah it is yeah yeah and uh he
called me and he was like what about
what if we go to Iceland instead he's
like it's gonna be way cheaper it's
really cool I was like yeah I'll go to
Iceland and then uh we went we were
supposed to go fishing the whole plan
was to go fishing okay bought a fly
fishing rod and everything okay you ever
fly fish before I have like once or
twice
stuff like that yeah no actually my
buddy taught me but yeah I I I I kind of
it's pretty it's not that hard I gotcha
and uh we did not catch a single fish
nor did we even see a fish the entire
time it was way too early in the season
dude we were like waiting like we had
like the whole like the jumpsuits on and
stuff when we were in the water and uh
yeah two hours in we like bought like uh
permits to go to this private 22 year
old kid goes to Iceland in April to go
fly it was was that something you do
when you retire it was like the first
week of May and
dude you're just staring in the water
I'm like not only are there no fish in
here I don't think anything is even
alive in this water and there's no
chicks it's a deal dude it was it was
devastating devastating but it was still
fun as [__] I mean we don't get a blast
we just got hammered the whole time did
you eat anything crazy like whale
blubber or anything like that oh no we
had some shark fish no I didn't have
anything I had like some good like just
regular fish you're a seafood guy yeah
shrimp cocktail I love shrimp cocktails
on a half shell yeah I didn't like
oysters until recently actually that's
understandable yeah okay but shrimp I
love shrimp all right uh how are you
getting your steak cooked uh
medium rare gentlemen yeah not bad you
know how to use chopsticks no like I
could I could figure out a way to use
them but not definitely not buy them out
to use them now okay any cologne using
any cologne no never what's the
deodorant situation Old Spice okay yeah
do you have a couple different ones or
just one just one just one Fiji Fiji
yeah okay classy tropical
tropical when was the last time you went
clothes shopping and where was it oh man
uh
I feel like you buy a lot of your
clothes off Amazon I feel now I I oh my
pants are Old Navy everything is Old
Navy I I actually really have to go
clothes shopping and get shirts for the
summer okay because I I I just threw out
a [__] ton of stuff and uh
when I moved
because I just get a bunch of [__] from
bar stool and like I'm never gonna wear
this and I have like mountains of it I
just threw it all away but uh
yeah Uniqlo Uniqlo is good okay yeah Old
Navy okay yeah all right all right fly
fishing yeah that's why that's the first
time I've heard that one what do you
normally eat for breakfast
uh
a protein bar and a Red Bull
every single day gotta start the engine
somehow yeah what's your protein bar of
choice Quest okay yeah like a Quest Bar
new guy Luke likes the quest bars yeah
quest bars are good you ever had a quail
egg no okay
will you stack plates at a restaurant
like when you're done eating will you
stack them up for the server no no like
if if everyone else is doing it then
yeah but it's never I've never had the
thought to do that
because I I honestly don't think it
helps them that much okay yeah I mean
I'm I yeah I think it's not the right
thing to do but that's just me will you
sleep with your socks on no no what are
you sleeping in just your undies
underwear and shirt okay yeah underwear
and a t I bet you flossing every day no
go to the dentist regularly no
haven't been since high school really
need to no flossing uh like occasionally
I gotta get better at about all this
what's the toothpaste situation what are
you using Crest Crest yeah gentlemen
electric toothbrush or regular regular
okay were you ever really into Harry
Potter no I like the movies okay movies
were good
what
that's just funny because you
theoretically you should yeah and I
wouldn't make fun of them because I'm
like that's you were [__] nice you
should you should have crushed through
all those books yeah I was never a big
reader Growing Up So any baking soda in
your refrigerator no
there's no room for it sure use a George
Foreman grill
have I used one before yeah yeah
probably okay hmm have you ever washed
your shoes in the washing machine no
dishwasher no
okay they keep the box of things like if
you get a new pair of sneakers will you
keep the box for a little while
um I probably have done that do you
still have the box of your PlayStation
no no TV no I just threw that out yeah
and what PlayStation is it what version
four four yeah you want to get a five
yeah when it comes time to get one right
now there's not enough like it's not
necessary yet okay I can still play all
the games you stay pretty current and
all that stuff I mean I've had a
PlayStation 4 for [__] ever I think I
got that when I was in ninth grade like
right when it came out really yeah it's
been around for a while and just that
still you get the best games and stuff
on there still can play everything it's
starting the fans been working overtime
recently so I think
it was the game I think the games are
too big for the for the console now you
vape in the apartment I assume yeah I'm
gonna I gotta quit it smoke weed in
there no I don't smoke weed you don't
smoke weed no I went through like a weed
phase but I never that's it never caught
on Edibles now I took Edibles once and I
I was by myself in my apartment in
Hell's Kitchen I used to live in Hell's
Kitchen and uh I took like one gummy and
I forgot I took it and then I'd like
rolled over to go to bed and the whole
room moved it like in slow motion and
then I was like holy [__] I am so high
and I had to it was a battle just a
battle the whole night gotcha and when
you booze what are you having I think
you're drinking buds the other night
yeah any light any light beer okay yeah
or or heavy I like Guinness Guinness is
good okay all right do you have a
working printer at the house no no
you own binoculars no hmm coming up were
you ever subscribed to Jake Paul's
YouTube channel now that that's so much
younger than me that's that's years yeah
that's like kids are like
12 now yeah yeah except is Jake Paul I
think people hate Jake Paul now or still
right I think Logan Paul kind of
recovered after the whole I think
they're both doing very well yeah
they're both very very big yeah I don't
know
plus they do me up I'll give you the two
piece yeah yeah huh have you ever want
to kiss me I'm Iris t-shirt no no okay
can you play any instruments uh yeah I I
play the piano and play the clarinet
okay yeah today you can play the
clarinet I could play like a scale I
don't know if I could read music that
well on the clarinet anymore you can
actually read music though yeah I I I
can read like a a scale and then I would
probably have to like count it out and I
could read pretty well on the piano
that's pretty impressive if I but it
would take me like a minute sure yeah
figure [__] out have you ever seen Star
Wars yeah seen that Return of the Jedi
Empire yeah I've seen all the old school
yeah okay you have name brand luggage no
oh I have a Nike duffel bag
yeah
it's easy with every use of underwear
yeah yeah God damn okay hey everybody's
22 candy I know I know I know do you own
a hair dryer no
hmm huh well you eat in the car
yeah when you eat in the back of an Uber
depends on how long the Uber is and if
you're drunk I said if I'm drunk if I'm
drunk 100 yeah okay like pizza slice of
pizza oh yeah 100 okay sometimes I go on
the way to the airport I'll have like an
egg sandwich oh that's fine
um when was the last time you slept in
your jeans
oh recently I assumed uh
[__] I got hammered recently and I fell
asleep like on the couch with all my
clothes on woke up with my shoes on oh
dude yeah
that ain't good that honestly might have
been the last time I hung out with you
guys yeah sure yeah yeah
I think I did the same thing
yeah
any colored contacts in your past no no
ever gone ghost hunting
no I've been bitten by a dog
whoo
no not like aggressively now okay yeah
has anybody you or anybody in your
family ever claimed to have seen a UFO
oh I bet my grandma has okay if she she
loves all that [__] okay cheese like
stores like pills in case of the
Apocalypse she stores pills she's got
like a bunker okay I know she still does
because they moved to like an old people
home but she had to she was like she had
like a bottle of Oxycontin and was like
no I'm not taking I'm saving it for the
Apocalypse
I don't know what the thought process
was I guess she was like if I get hurt
if I get caught with pills that's what
I'm gonna do
hey Paul my grandpa used to smoke and he
had a he would keep a lighter and a
cigarette in a cigarette box in his
glove compartment after he quit in case
the end of the world happened so he
could smoke one more cigarette I would
probably that probably made it easy for
him to quit of like I have one right
there in case that's the one I'm gonna
have they sound like real relaxed people
try a couple of decafs
um
have you ever tried to start the wave at
a sporting event no no I'm not that's
not me crash crash a golf cart yeah
big time you have yeah spun out and
everything
no dipped
no uh it was like we we were going down
a hill
and it just started like out of nowhere
just uncontrollably spinning down a
steep hill and tipped okay yeah being in
trouble for it now there's nothing we
could really do about it sure I don't
think anyone even saw what was your
first concert
I haven't been to a lot of concerts uh I
went to a lot of it was this Festival in
Marshfield the town next to mine and it
was uh it was called levitate music
festival and it started out pretty small
it's like a very like like uh indie rock
reggae music and uh
so I've seen all of like the like Ziggy
Marley and all those guys about well she
seemed like uh
I don't know if you guys know stick
figure no probably not T-Bone
Tadashi trucks
uh
you can stop me stupid yeah
stupid all right just go back to dinner
say you and your boys do go out to eat
will you guys get a couple appetizers
and share it or is everything
compartmentalized per person
you compartment compartment yeah we
don't really share much really yeah kind
of just get what you want huh okay
appetizers honestly a new thing to me I
was never a big appetizers guy you just
go right to the meal I like bread okay
bread and oil hey I'm right there with
you yeah guy you're preaching to the
choir
[Music]
I get I mean talk about not being able
to get a reader I know he's a young guy
he's doing well
when did you get your mattress off the
floor
uh
uh I mean when I moved to New York I was
on the floor I didn't even have a
mattress yeah I slept on an air mattress
on the kitchen floor at somebody's
apartment so then like I got he's
killing us we're not saying that I mean
oh yeah I'm not throwing Jade at the guy
we were in that house on Titan Street in
South Philly I had a futon but I was in
front of the laundry you were in a futon
in the basement and I had a box spring
like a you know right that's what
they're called like the wooden frame
yeah that was on the ground that I had a
mattress on that so I was a little
elevated it wasn't just mattress
that was probably what is it though like
so I I'm not it's not like I've never
had a mattress uh a bed frame of course
like I had one in my old apartment I
just didn't feel like moving it sure so
I just left it there so it's just a
mattress it's just a mattress and you
have a down comforter I assume yeah how
many pillows two two pillows yeah you
sleep with them both under your head or
you're hugging one
uh dude I I actually I
sometimes I don't even use the pillows I
don't I don't hate just head on the
mattress
you might be you might live in Rikers
your own work release dude you go back
to a jail cell I like to put my arm here
and rest my head on my arm I don't hate
like a hobo yeah but it's comfortable
and then and then I'll wake up and I'll
put the pillow I'll use the pillow huh
you ever break anything as a kid you
break your arms or broke my arm birth
grade fifth grade yeah bad or the how'd
you do it uh tripped over a lunch box I
had a lunchbox what a long strap and I
was running to my next class and I
tripped wait you had a lunchbox with a
long strap yeah
wait what that's a purse yeah but it was
a it was a lunch box it was like the
cooler lunch box type sure and I [__]
took a dick a dive you freak out rolled
I rolled around squirming in pain and
then the nurse came and brought me but I
didn't I never cried okay yeah it was
more just like
it's like it's like Dickie Ward I never
yeah I never you never got you never got
me down yeah I was honestly kind of
pumped to have a cast
oh yeah were you a popular kid in high
school uh no no I wouldn't say so I was
very very quiet girlfriend in high
school uh no have you had a serious
girlfriend thus far yeah yeah okay yeah
did you go to prom yeah
how did you get to that problem did you
take a limo did you drive drove you
drove we would drive to the school and I
would just drive in a normal car and
then uh she drove the Arcadia yeah
pretty much yeah actually I think I did
I think I drove me and like 10 people
because it seats eight people it's a big
car big ride yeah and uh did you did you
soak the Windows like prom no no no no
what year did you go you see with the
problem and what 20
17 2017 what year did you graduate high
school 2019
that's crazy yeah it is crazy it is
weird I think 29. when you look at it
like that I mean you're [__] killing
it yeah the place in the West Village
yeah
at 42.
he was living under our Buddy's kitchen
table
with the Trash Pack full of belongings
and I didn't have no PlayStation 4.
young man yeah you guys are [__]
killing it
it's [__] insane this is the nicest
like I went to columns one and I was
like this is nuts and did bar stools got
to take a [__] look at this place
that was wild yeah we
took all the money we've ever made and
put it in here you guys rent out those
other ones no that's other Studios and
offices oh really yeah
do you like the smell of asphalt
gasoline horses or magic marker uh at uh
asphalt and gasoline yeah the other ones
I've never really picked up on okay have
you ever ridden a horse
yeah four uh I went to get to school
[Music]
I was visiting one of my buddies who
worked on a ranch in Wyoming and uh he
was a cook there and how long ago is
this this was it makes it seem like he's
a hundred years old I know I was just
like Ranch in Wyoming
stew you said you said your one buddy
was like a chef who a 22 year old Chef
yeah dude everyone's [__] got like
thrown off because we all got sent home
from college and everyone's like I want
to do online classes and live at home
for the next year so like he moved to
Denver and got a job out there and and
lived on [__] unemployment for a year
man and then he went to this Ranch in
the summer and got a
got a job there and it was pretty cool I
went I went out and uh it's like a it's
like a ranch for rich people like he
lived he worked there gotcha it's like a
touristy Ranch but I got to go and just
live in his room sure and uh they had
like a horse riding [__] thing and I
went on it a little tour do you think if
if the pandemic never happens you stay
in school and yeah and did you apply to
Barstool no they reached out to me what
were you doing in school that got their
attention uh I was like I was on Twitter
guy yeah yeah okay yeah yeah I was doing
good on it yeah I was making videos and
stuff okay dumb little sketches
I am yeah interesting guy very 22. yeah
well living a life he's been to Iceland
and a ranch in Wyoming yeah I got I mean
I I you know is he trash
no I mean I think he what Toby what
Toby's eyes are popping out of his head
yeah man why why he sleeps on the floor
bad meeting the mini fridge
it's a better neighborhood than all of
us we've never graded on an age curve
before we've never had someone this
young it's true he can't rent a car all
right hand that's actually a big issue
and me and Francis just did a
gotta take your mom on the road with you
that's it's actually a massive problem
Francis is pitching about the sandwiches
dude it's a huge issue I had to pick
Francis up at an air at uh what is the
airport in DC dollars duelist I don't
know Dulles yeah I had to pick him up
there and I was supposed to drive down
and pick him up because we had to get a
show in West Virginia and uh and he
doesn't want to hear any answers like
that oh no yeah I can't get the car yeah
slapping though yeah
yeah
and uh get your assistance
and uh I I a dude hurts swears that they
rent cars people that are under 25
they're like their whole like one of
their whole Logan their slogans is like
uh oh under 25 we got you covered and
then I went and they were like shocked
when I had them the ID they were like we
don't have any of the cars that we can
give you like we can put you on a wait
list I got a Toyota with training wheels
yeah I'm like who's renting a car that's
able to be put on a wait list yeah
usually it's like I gotta go right now
I'm not just going for a cruise dude I
can't wait till tomorrow for the [__]
Toyota
you were supposed to drive down to DC
and pick him up yeah and take him where
uh we were supposed to go to West
Virginia okay so how did you work that
out I got a zip car and then I got
banned from Zipcar because you weren't
25. no so Zipcar you can rent under 25
but they're going out of business so if
they're if you do like one thing wrong
they'll shut you down they're looking
for reasons
I was late returning the car by like
three hours and they were like calling
me and [__] and then the account they're
like your account's not registered
anymore huh
but you saved the heat from Francis I
did Francis [__] me on that by the way
why the [__] am I driving to wall I
could have just taken a train we could
have ubered to the place that we were
going and then the whole thing was like
oh it'll be trying to learn you yeah it
was the whole thing was like we could
well we could it'll be easier we can
just drive we don't have to get in
because we're doing in the middle of
nowhere we're doing Casino in literally
the middle of nowhere in West Virginia
like it would have taken us I would be
surprised if we could even have gotten
an Uber and
we're going home and he's like by the
way I'm not actually going back to New
York he's like I I'm going to my
sister's house in Maryland so he's like
you can just drop me off like 10 minutes
into the drive so then I just had to
drive eight hours back by myself oh [__]
that yeah you should have been on a
train yeah yeah huh he's got a fresh
bottle of Rose
he's got his bathing suit on that's a
real funny Dynamic man yeah
you stick with him he's a classy guy
yeah he's Francis a good guy yeah I I I
I honestly I don't I
I can't call him track I can't call him
Trice he's young he's a young boy you
know what I mean I think you're [__]
killing it I think
I mean are you starting to you can get a
vacuum get a broom start with that yeah
for the apartment you can tighten it up
yeah do you have interest in those kind
of things a vacuum in a broom
does anyone have interest in those what
are your thoughts on the room yeah
okay bringing a floor model yeah try to
sell you an Electrolux no but like do
you are you at the age now
where you want to like start being more
grown up in the in those things that
you're not really thinking about it
don't give a [__] what do you [__] do
dude I was a [__] mess you were a
mess a couple of months ago the problem
is I don't have no I don't have any like
I think I could live How I Live Forever
that's that's the young kid thing of
course not the same way but it's also
you have to look at like his influences
are other 22 year old kids sure and or
stand-up comics who are us so it's like
it's not like he has a group of friends
who is like you know stock Brokers and
[__] yeah who's your favorite singer
oh
Bob Dylan really yeah okay that's pretty
been a Bob Dylan fan for a while
who are you listening to who do you like
that's that's cool now
I just want to know in case anybody
asked me
I don't really know I don't I I can look
at what my music all my music saved is
like [__] who's your favorite actor
favorite actor
oh that's a tough one right now who do
you like
I go through big phases right now I'm
going on a big Json Bateman phase
kid's all right man I Bateman
Bateman's not bad payments [__] rules
what are you talking about Leo I mean
obviously Leo's everything of course
I don't I I
mean
interesting interesting yeah you gotta
get 22. kid's classy man uh you can't
say that I'm not saying he's awesome
definitely awesome
yeah his Squad sounds awesome he's got
his buddy out on a ranch but he has a
dirt bag he's 22 years old I know
I know we'll have to revisit in a couple
of years are you reading anything do you
read uh uh no I I try to okay what are
you trying to read uh I read Sam
talent's book it was really good okay
I've ever had uh shout out to Sammy T I
read I read all of Charles Bukowski's
books
okay I read uh doll Jack kerouac's books
okay I mean 22 year old reading this
[__] has his own apartment I think that
that tattoo those books are for yeah but
I bet you run for your little Las Vegas
too oh yeah but I would say I didn't
read those though I would say there's a
drug guy he's not a drug guy either no
if you're in Loathing in Las Vegas is
phenomenal of course and I would say
kids you're your age now they're not
that connected to those those things yes
those were but I mean most 22 year old
kids aren't saying they're famous their
favorite singers Bob Dylan yeah
I I would say that no one under the age
of 30 can talk [__] to you because
you're no killed it I can't talk [__] to
him
yeah yeah
I gotta show this to everyone from high
school yeah they said no one can talk
[__] to me you see these two fat-fold
losers they said don't be mean to me I
come up here
do you have a watch I got a Fitbit okay
even that's responsible
but I haven't worn it in a [__] year
ah bad yeah I listen yeah
I say you're classy I say you're doing
all right he's doing all right I'll give
him that that's that's that'll be my
call he's doing all right he's doing all
right I don't want to like go for
anything you know what I mean like I
don't want to like steer you guys no
I'll just genuinely the I but I think if
you saw how I lived you would not say
it's not a break you're classy yeah
you're not he's not classy where are you
getting your toilet paper and how many
rolls of toilet paper are in the house I
ordered a bunch on Amazon [__] when I
moved in I still have a bunch and
where's that sitting is it in a closet
so it's in a box in the living room see
okay all right
you got paper towels in the house I do
how many bath towels do you own
one it's 22 22 though I have two and I'm
40.
I only have two because I'm married
where are you putting the uh the bath
towel when you're done with it is it
hanging over the door in your bedroom or
is it behind it's got there's a I just
found out recently there's a hook on the
door so I put it up on that I just found
out recently
ha
I should call the guy who lives do you
have a rug in the living room a carpet
right now no rugs I gotta get all this
[__] I was just thinking about this the
other day I got to get all this [__] you
just moved in yeah but the thing is like
the only reason I would get any of this
stuff is because it's like the what
people suggest that you do like so if
people come over you're not like oh my
God I need to get up
trouble in my house let me ask you this
when your friends come over to your
house what do they say this place is
great or are they like what the [__] are
you doing no one's really been there huh
ah my buddy my buddy came over actually
recently but he we were we came over for
like an hour we were hammered and we
fell asleep and then he woke up at like
6 a.m so he had to get to get on the
train
he's probably pumped that he had a couch
there's a couch to sleep on brand new
cat where'd you get the couch from
Amazon
it's a good couch it's a good a
comfortable couch
you'd think twice about making that
noise
[Laughter]
it's a hell of a I've actually slept on
the couch by choice multiple times sure
it's right by the TV I did it last night
I did it last night dude it's good will
you fall asleep watching TV uh I can but
also a part of me I can't like I get to
look I you ever put on a podcast when
you're going to bed yeah sure but I I
then I end up I'm like dude I've been
listening to this podcast for two hours
with my eyes closed like I'll I'll I'll
only do it when I'm drunk I have to be
like really [__] up yeah if I'm [__]
up I can put on anything and fall asleep
sure so when you go to bed at night
usually are you going you're turning
everything off all the lights off in
your room all the lights are off I tried
like I always am like I want to listen
to a podcast I'll throw a podcast on and
then an hour and I'm like I'm not gonna
fall asleep if this stays on so you go
to bed with complete darkness
that's pretty hanging from his ankles
that's [__] weird dudes yeah man
taxi driver I don't know he's a wee I'm
not saying he's not weird he's well he's
a weird kid he's the Enigma dude yeah
he's a weird
trashy successful
strange strange 16 72 year olds yeah
I will say when we were on that vacation
we're like dude next time let's just go
somewhere nice yeah and just sit on a
[__] chair yeah
you're a moose
dude we would just drive all day because
you gotta drive everywhere and then we
would just get and we'd go to like we'd
find the one bar in Iceland and we would
you guys ever have girls no it's like a
light beard out there they're damn good
yeah good beer a couple of dolls if I
was in the ice block if I was an
Icelandic state trooper and I pulled you
two over
I'd have a lot of questions yeah dude
there's there's none there's no laws out
there yeah it's pretty wide open I think
there's I think I looked up there's like
700 police officers in the entire
country
we saw one police officer the whole time
no trouble though
everyone kind of covers themselves yeah
I mean everyone's so spread out I'm sure
like Reiki we didn't go to Reykjavik for
that long which is like the major city
but I'm sure there they probably have
more police
well it is what we're gonna have to do
where I mean we should this should be
like 100 how the showroom we should
check in with you every every two years
yeah come in and see where you're at
take show us pictures of your apartment
it's probably gonna get a lot worse
lose the couch yeah yeah you guys cool
if I crash here after we record
yeah I would like I would I would like
to I would like to see you a year from
now yeah yeah one year from now I'd love
to I bet he's real classy a year from
now
that's my only time will tell I just
don't think a year with Francis yeah but
dude Francis we just grew up so
different like my dad's not classy my
dad grew up in Long Island okay it comes
from dirt bags and my mom yeah my mom
grew up in Hyannis in Cape Cod
that's nice though isn't it Hyannis is
not nice isn't Cape Cod I thought Cape
Cod was yeah I think there's obviously
different parts of it Hyannis has a
[__] heroin problem bad okay but all
Masters there's nothing wrong with that
no all right we gotta wrap it up though
Lil sass yeah thanks for having me yeah
that's [__] fantastic such a fun
format anything you want the folks out
there to know what do you got coming up
let me just hop onto little Sasquatch
website and see what we got coming out
little sasquatch.com is available by the
way yeah I don't know what the hell we
were thinking with that you gotta talk
to your team talk to the other four guys
I [__] I [__] wish this was coming
out this week because I could really use
that problem Ontario I'm gonna be in I
guess like I could definitely use it on
this Huntsville Alabama Huntsville
Alabama stand up live I'm gonna be there
July 14th the 15th and then I want to
see him to be in [__] uh Atlanta at
some point in July too so keep an eye
out for that yeah there's a bunch of
homies and bozos in Atlanta go check out
sass 100 super funny [__] fantastic
uh we're all over the road we're
announcing uh the second leg of the tour
for the Fallen big drop coming soon get
those tickets because a lot of those
markets are going to sell out so get
them while they last thanks for the
support we'd love you we love you and
we'll see you next week peace